Clement area is tagged yes I row
he's been involved in
modeling for a long long time now has
been one of the earliest people doing
sophisticated beautiful model and
particularly excited and strong and
trying to think about not just a bit
about 40 minute of species and how to
mod 11 space so it's a real a real
leader in that our people I'm also very
active when the science policy on point
interface and hopefully be able to get
that going
it's a particular things from climbing
the promoter wake of affairs in about
four days weeks of our first sabbatical
visitors to the program fire away Simon
thinks thanks very much Walter as the
symposium goes on it's getting harder
and harder to say something that hasn't
already been said and for those of you
who were here yesterday you'll notice
that this diagram looks very similar to
one that Ben Colin put up yesterday so
there's some nice some convergent
evolution going on in our in our
thinking I'm going to be talking about
33 biodiversity challenges assessment
challenges and Ben did touch on these
yesterday the the first of these is to
do with observing change in biodiversity
pasture to present the second challenge
is about trying to project what is going
to happen to biodiversity or could
happen to biodiversity in the future in
other words scenario analysis and the
third challenge is the one of then using
modeling of what we think might happen
to know that future trajectory of
biodiversity if we were to implement
different types of policies or
management actions as a basis for
prioritizing and making decisions in
relation to those actions okay now when
we look at that state of biodiversity
y-axis there we can imagine that that
that can be assessed at many different
spatial scales and i should say right up
front and this again gets back to
something that was talked about
yesterday and that is that most of my
previous experience before moving to
CSIRO four years ago was actually within
a state government
environmental agency and so most of the
work that I was involved with was
actually at the state or regional or
landscape scale and it was was all about
planning and decision-making so just to
give you a bit of that that background
on where I've come from I've actually
come from a background where I've been
involved in in real world
decision-making at the landscape scale
Loretha at the regional scale and so my
interests in thinking at whole continent
scale or global scales is relatively
recent okay so this can happen at
different spatial scales we can also
think of state of biodiversity as being
assessed in relation to different
dimensions and levels of biodiversity
and so there I've just got an adaptation
of the old Reno's perspective on on on
the dimensions and levels of
biodiversity and when when we look at
that and we think back to to Woody's
talk then it becomes obvious that there
are there are some levels and dimensions
of biodiversity that a lot easier to
assess remotely than others so things
like ecosystem structure and function
people are doing a reasonably good job
of assessing those remotely but when we
come to composition other than some of
those things that would he mentioned
like um the aristocratic be trees for
example that you can now assess to some
extent with hyperspectral imagery most
of the composition of biodiversity of
the species and genetic level quite
obviously we're not in a position to
assess that remotely so this presents
some some very real challenges and so
I'm going to be focusing most of my talk
on this compositional dimension of
biodiversity and on the challenge
of assessing that at the global scale
and if we look at how people have have
approached this this problem before
there are two commonly employed
approaches in global assessments of
compositional biodiversity one of which
is to look at a tour to work with
distributions for example range maps of
species in better known biological
groups such as the the vertebrates and
Walter talked a lot about this yesterday
and another fairly commonly used
approaches one where people focus on
mapped ecosystem types of biomes or or
ecoregions and essentially use those as
course filter surrogates for
biodiversity composition and use
approaches like species area
relationships to infer what's happening
in terms of the retention of
compositional diversity but there's been
a lot of work done over the years and I
was involved a lot with this sort of
about twenty years ago of evaluating how
well some of these surrogate approaches
perform for the unsurveyed elements of
biodiversity or now or in other words
the other 99 percent of biodiversity so
all of the you know the invertebrates
the lower and higher plants that the
microbes and so on what how well are
these catered for by these these
surrogate approaches and I think you
know to to summarize that the story
there the the results of a lot of those
assessments have been have been quite
mixed so there are some real issues with
using things like vertebrate species
ranges and broadly mapped ecosystem
types and ecoregions and so on as
surrogates for the rest of biodiversity
or the other 99 percent but then on the
other hand we know that for a lot of
these neglected groups there's a there's
a surprising amount of information out
there and this is just one example of a
group that we were just starting to do
some modeling with at the moment
globally the the diptera or true flies
and when you look at that group there
are over three million records for
almost 120,000 species of of diptera
within GBF there's also now quite a
superb high-level phylogeny of the whole
dip Duras so this is quite an amazing
amount of information on a group like
that okay but as you would have seen
from that that map on the left there the
geographic coverage of those records is
is patchy in there that there are big
gaps so we don't have geographically
complete data hence the idea of
integrating in situ or field surveyed
biological data with remotely mapped
environmental variables and Woody's
already talked about this quite a bit
and and this can be used the most basic
level just a model spatial pattern in
the distribution of biodiversity if we
get a little bit more sophisticated we
can bring in remotely observe change in
ecosystem state or intactness to infer
changes in the status of biodiversity
and then in turn we can get down here to
bringing in projected pressures and
responses things like climate change
land-use change to project biodiversity
into the future so Woody's talked a fair
bit about this so i won't i won't dwell
on that too long but just jump straight
to this slide which is just simply to to
point out that you know as soon as you
mentioned linking biological data and
remotely mapped environmental data a lot
of people immediately assume that you're
talking about species distribution
modeling or or niche modeling that's
that's certainly one very important
strategy for linking these sources of
information and I've spent a lot of my
career deriving species distribution
models I modeled my first species in
1982 and
model many thousands of species in that
in the 15 or 20 years following that but
speech distribution modeling is just one
way of integrating these sources of
information and a lot of options there
that I won't go into if you're
interested in learning more about that
then have a look at that review paper
that I wrote with Antoine he signed a
few years ago and journal of applied
ecology but I just wanted to focus on
the two ends of the spectrum there one
end is the individual species
distribution modeling that we're all
very familiar with but down at the other
end of the spectrum here is is another
approach which we're now using quite
heavily is it which is what we call
macro macro ecological modelling of
collective biodiversity properties and
so this is modeling things like richness
and and compositional turnover across
space and i'll be talking about this in
a little bit more detail soon but the
point I wanted to make here is that you
know we've got all of these different
modeling strategies and its really
horses for the courses that the
appropriateness of different strategies
depends very much on the question of
interest and the nature of the
biological group that you're working
with and how much data you've got within
that group so if you're if you're
working with a group like birds where
society places value on each and every
bird species and they all have names
that people are familiar with and so on
and you've got a reasonable number of
records per species then it makes sense
to be modeling individual species
distributions but if you get down to
this end of the spectrum here where you
know the group you're working on people
aren't really valuing the individual
species within it but we do value the
overall diversity of that group and also
we've got a huge number of species in
that group a lot of them are very few
records and probably a lot that don't
have any records at all and we don't
even know that those species exist then
this other kind of strategy might make a
lot more
sense in that situation so what do I
mean by modeling collective properties
biodiversity this is probably fairly
obvious that the one that has been done
a lot more is where people model local
richness or alpha diversity so the
something like the species diversity at
a location as a function of the
environment of let that location the
biogeographic history human disturbance
and and so on or it becomes a lot more
interesting when we start to also bring
in consideration of the compositional
dissimilarity between locations or in
other words beater or beta diversity and
trying to model that as a function of
differences in the abiotic environment
between those locations the level of bio
geographic isolation and those those
sorts of things now with with all of
this modeling we can be talking about
just simple measures of species richness
or compositional dissimilarity in terms
of species overlap or we can get a
little bit more sophisticated and
bringing considerations of phylogeny so
all of these modeling approaches have
have phylogenetic versions of them now
just to bring this to life a bit here's
an example of work that we've done
within the whole Australian continent
going back a couple of years now we're
here we're focusing primarily on
modeling those those patterns of beta
diversity or patterns of compositional
turnover across the Australian continent
and this is a rather different approach
to the individual species modeling
approach in that this is a model in this
case here and sorry if you can't see
those those fitted functions there
they've obviously very faint on the
screen but the important point is that
this this is a model that's working with
compositional turnover as a collective
property of this particular
group which for the example I've got
here is is land snails and we've modeled
lots and lots of different biological
groups within Australia but you know
this is a model that's fitted to a whole
lot of data for almost 3,000 species of
land snails so we're looking at all the
data for land snails together within a
single model relating that to
environmental variables to do with
climate terrains soils also bringing
consideration of geographic isolation
into the modeling and this is all used
to then say something about the spatial
pattern in the distribution of
biodiversity for that particular group
in this case the land stones across the
Australian continent and so that then in
turn is used if we do that for a lot of
different biological groups that then
provides the basis for doing all sort of
sorts of assessments that are built on
top of that this is just one example of
work in the last couple of years where
we've done climate change impact
analyses based on those sorts of models
to help inform national scale policy
development and planning okay but what's
all this got to do with with the global
scale well we we first had to go at
applying these kinds of approaches at a
global scale and the lead up to the
fifth world parks congress in 2003 and
we were essentially complementing some
of that work that got reported yesterday
work done by tom brooks and others by
showing as a proof of concept how you
could apply our sorts of approaches to
best available biological data sets
drawn from representative combinations
of by geographic relman biome and linked
to best available environmental layers
at that point in time so this was used
as the basis for assessing the
representativeness of the global
protected area network in the years
since then a lot
has has changed and has has moved
forward so we're now in a position where
I think that a lot of new opportunities
opened up for the application of these
approaches because we've got things like
GBF and related initiatives have really
moved forwards in leaps and bounds over
the past almost 10 years we've got all
the work that that woody was talking
about with geo and gos in terms of Earth
Observation there's a whole lot of work
happening with global scenario analyses
with things like the image model and
we've also got these these new policy
initiatives relating to the convention
on biological diversity and the new AEG
targets and also the emergence of of IP
best so it's a that there's suddenly
this new window of opportunity to apply
some of these techniques in a more
rigorous way and so we about a year ago
had another go at a proof of concept
analysis that made use of some of these
approaches using the improved
information that it's now available and
this is very much as I said
proof-of-concept it's just to give
people that the flavor of what might be
possible hope hoping to then leverage
the sorts of resources that are needed
to really roll this out properly so in
this case and I won't have time to go
into it in great detail we're bringing
together the best available data on all
the fern species for the world over 1.3
million records for about 10,000 species
of ferns from from gb combining that
with best available environmental data
land-use change layers at a fairly
coarse resolution from the the image
model climate change projections
bringing all this together with modeling
approaches that I won't go into in
detail now but happy to talk about them
with anyone later bringing all that
together to then say something about
what we think is happening to the
attention of compositional diversity
within this group okay that that then
allows us to to say something about the
expected changes at different spatial
resolutions I won't try to explain that
one in detail but the important point is
that because of the way we do this and
the way we're considering our for beta
and gamma diversity we can in fact
aggregate up these results to different
spatial scales so we can say something
about what we think is happening for
example with an individual ecoregion
with a whole biogeographic realm or even
with with the whole planet ok just to
very quickly run through what are some
of the current directions in the
application of these these kinds of
approaches and some of this has already
been touched on by others so i won't i
won't dwell on parts of it but in terms
of that the types of biological data
that we can use in this kind of of
modeling clearly you know citizen
science is changing the whole ballgame
there but the other big change now is is
environmental metagenomics and we're
working a lot now with people who are
doing metagenomics not just for microbes
but also now for things like arthropods
and you know this is a way of going out
and getting these big grab samples of
the environment using fast throughput
sequencing to get a complete profile of
the biodiversity within those those
samples so this is this is a big step
forward woody's done a superb job of
covering the remote sensing end of
things I won't dwell on this but
obviously hyperspectral lidar and radar
again changes and there's a lot of very
exciting work happening with the
derivation of new fine scaled a biotic
surfaces climate and soils etc I've just
got one example they're drawn from work
of some of my CSIRO colleagues
in Canberra who are all linked into this
big new global initiative in fact
CSIRO's one of the leaders of the global
soil map initiative which is trying to
transform the way that soil attributes
are mapped globally and so they have
been trialing approaches that are going
to be rolled out globally for mapping
soil attributes from remote sensing
integrated with a whole lot of other
sources of information and various forms
of modeling so that's that's a very
exciting step forwards in terms of
directions in modeling spatial pattern
in the distribution of biodiversity
we've been doing a lot of work on
smarter ways of incorporating phylogeny
accounting for by geographic history and
also dealing with the ever-present
issues of a bias than incompleteness in
biological sampling we've also been
doing a lot of work on on getting
smarter about how we do biodiversity
projections under global change
scenarios incorporating ecological
mechanisms and processes into our models
and also starting to get serious about
accounting for the capacity for
evolutionary adaptation in these
projections and if I could just flash up
a couple of examples of that this is
work led by one of my my postdocs from
the past three years where he this is
Carell McCarney he's been extending the
sorts of macro ecological models that
we've been used to project future
changes in biodiversity he's been
extending those models to better
consider aspects of ecological processes
so so so that's it so in this case
community assembly rules and and and
dispersal are actually incorporated into
that modeling and in terms of i
mentioned capacity for evolutionary
adaptation this is work that is just
starting up and this is a very big
project a joint project between CSIRO
Melbourne University and monash
university which is looking at the
genomics of climate adaptation and
that's actually using a number of of
model groups of organisms to a
Drosophila is one eucalyptus is another
and there are a few more but but
essentially they're working on getting a
lot smarter about being able to to
predict estimate or infer the evolution
evil the capacity for evolutionary
adaptation across some different sets of
organisms and so the the drosophila are
quite an extraordinary group to work
with in this regard I think woody was
talking about the whole enchilada before
the drosophila are definitely the whole
enchilada they have for within Australia
for the drosophila group they they know
absolutely everything you would ever
want to know about this group in terms
of what it does in or what climate
change does to the group right through
to running experimental evolution under
climate change so it's it's quite
amazing and this is going to provide the
most superb testbed for then evaluating
all sorts of other approaches the people
have used to model biological responses
to the climate change okay then finally
this box out to the side here which i
haven't mentioned so far which is a
critically important one and that is the
the evaluation and calibration of some
of these sort of remotely derived models
of what's happening to biodiversity and
evaluating and calibrating knows using
long term field monitoring plots
ecological plots and biodiversity plots
a really crucial part of the whole story
and then there's also potential here to
to make use of things like paleo
ecological data to to evaluate the
performance of these
it's just to touch on that very quickly
because I know Walter wants to catch up
on time but this is just an example of
where within Australia we're putting a
lot of work into sort of trying to link
these two communities of practice the
the the more sort of remotely derived
model-based approaches to debate and
biodiversity assessment and then the
community of practice that is more
geared towards going out and repeatedly
surveying biodiversity at that field
plots over time and so we're really
interested in better ways of actually
integrating these these two approaches
and getting the right feedback loops
going on in there in terms of
calibration and and evaluation and then
with the paleoecological example this is
a paper that's that's just just out
that's based on ongoing work that I'm
doing with Jack Williams and and Jessica
Blois from University of Wisconsin where
you know they have this most incredible
fossil pollen dataset from the last
20,000 years that is essentially
allowing us to look at how well some of
our predictions of biodiversity change
over time based on these macro
ecological models hold up when you look
at what's actually happened in terms of
the pollen record so that's a whole
story in itself just the very last slide
Walter and um I think woody said that
the key word was integration and and
here it is I couldn't agree more the
whole challenge that we've got is one of
of integration and I think it's
integration across lots of different
dimensions so just to run through them
very quickly the challenges I see are
integrating change observation scenario
analysis and conservation planning which
at the moment sort of tend to operate in
parallel universes different communities
of practice integrating across scales
local regional and glow
Herbal integrating the compositional
structural and functional perspectives
on biodiversity obviously integrating
remote sensing and in situ observations
and also really importantly given what
I've just talked about the need to
integrate species level approaches and
macro ecological modeling approaches to
this integration of remote sensing and
in situ observations so so both are
really important they're highly
complementary and we've got to get
smarter about how we use them in
conjunction with each other thank you
thanks for keeping on time gives us time
for one or two questions but in a minute
of soup so you can already come up Mac
and get started but the questions
property
can you call me
if I had 10 minutes now we can be
holding a few min so so we can talk
afterwards yeah that that takes quite a
while very happy